Jean-Luc Picard is one of Star Trek's
most legendary captains but the man has
a long complicated history with the
Enterprise and its crew if you want the
lowdown on his story then here's
Picard's entire timeline explained born
in labar France young Jean-Luc Picard
had a troubled upbringing the first
glimpse of his childhood comes in the
Star Trek the Next Generation episode
titled family where he visits his
brother Robert on Earth in this episode
we learned that Jean-Luc and Robert
helped their father take care of the
family's Vineyards we also learned that
the rest of jean-luc's family are
traditionalists they don't trust
advanced technology like replicators and
certainly don't have a high opinion of
the vaunted Starfleet all the while his
brother is something of a bully to him
but we learn much more about the young
Picard's early life in season 2 of Star
Trek Picard apparently he had an
especially close relationship with his
mother Yvette but Yvette suffered from
severe mental illness and despite her
husband Maurice's pleas she refused to
seek help as a result adult Maurice is
often forced to lock her in her room to
prevent her from self-harm during
particularly difficult episodes this
leads to one of the most life-altering
moments in John Luke's life amid one of
his mother's episodes she calls out to
Jean-Luc to let her out of her room when
he does it leads to his mother's suicide
the card carries the guilt of this
incident with him all of his life only
finally coming to terms with it as an
older man
moving past the tragedy jean-luc's time
on the Family Vineyard continues to
frustrate him as he has little interest
in the family business of winemaking it
doesn't take long for Jean-Luc to figure
out that his path leads to the stars and
the future Enterprise Captain soon gains
a reputation as an overachiever becoming
a Sports Champion as well as
valedictorian of his high school the
short president of the School
Valedictorian at I think hero with her
arms raised
Victory against his father's wishes John
Luke leaves home for Starfleet Academy
as soon as the opportunity arises though
it takes him two attempts before his
application is accepted and season six's
tapestry we learn a little bit more
about what kind of man he is during his
Academy days far from the steady stoic
commanding leader Picard is a Brash
fiery Cavalier sort and even something
of a womanizer while at Starfleet
Academy it's there that he meets both
Jack Crusher and Beverly Howard and they
become close friends we also learned
that he had something of an unrequited
crush on Academy mate Marta botanides
but we also witnessed an event just
after his exit from the academy that
leaves its deepest mark on him while
waiting for his first assignments the
card gets into a brawl with a group of
nausicans over a game of Dumb jot
overmatched but refusing to back down
Picard is stabbed through the heart and
while he survives the injury he's left
with an artificial organ in his heart's
place
we don't have many details about
Picard's post-academy life before he got
command of his own ship we learn in the
second season TNG episode The Measure of
a Man that he once served aboard the USS
Reliant but more is known about his time
aboard the USS Stargazer there Picard
started as a bridge officer but he made
his way up the ranks the old-fashioned
way being the highest ranked officer
Left Alive in the middle of a battle
Jean-Luc commanded the Stargazer for two
decades until he and the surviving crew
were forced to abandon the vessel after
a battle with a Ferengi ship
by them
final battle led to the Picard maneuver
being coined for the unorthodox move
Jean-Luc made to destroy the enemy
vessel more personally relevant to
Picard was his friendship with Jack
Crusher aboard the Stargazer Jack was
the late husband of Beverly Crusher and
father to Wesley both of whom wind up
serving aboard the Enterprise it's
Picard who while commanding the
Stargazer sent Jack Crusher on an away
mission that led to his death
when we meet Picard in the Next
Generation series premiere he's already
taken command of his famous ship his
orders sent him to deneb IV Beyond which
lies the great unexplored Mass
the Galaxy on the way there the
Enterprise has its first fateful meeting
with the trickster god-like alien Q with
a few short breaks here and there Picard
remains in command of the Enterprise D
until its destruction in 1994's Star
Trek generations he and his stalwart
crew get to explore quite a bit of that
great unexplored mass and along the way
they encounter aliens both benevolent
and hostile including the fan favorite
Borg in the season 2 episode Q who the
deceitful Q uses his powers to send the
Enterprise deep into unexplored parts of
the Galaxy where they encounter the Borg
for the first time the Borg act as a
single Collective mind and rebuff all
attempts at Communication in favor of
seeking to overpower the Enterprise
although they're eventually returned to
Federation space it's clear the crew
hasn't seen the last of the Borg since
there were few existence
they will be coming the Borg re-emerge
in the two-parter The Best of Both
Worlds when they kidnap Picard and
assimilate him into their Collective
Picard is eventually rescued and it
proves the Borg's Achilles heel as his
connection to the collective allows data
to command the Invaders to sleep but
it's clear Picard is severely
traumatized by the experience this
wouldn't be Picard's last encounter with
the Borg however in iborg the Enterprise
crew rescue aborig who's somehow capable
of independent thought they meet him
again in the two-part descent as the
leader of a group of liberated Borg
resisting the control of data's twin
brother lore and finally Picard would be
forced to confront the Borg and his
overwhelming need for vengeance against
them in 1996's Star Trek first Contact
when the aliens attempt to assimilate
the Federation by going back in time
before the federation's founding one of
the most interesting relationships on
Star Trek the Next Generation is the
kinship that develops between Picard and
the Android data by the end of the
series and the subsequent films it's
clear Picard holds the Android close to
his heart he sees data as at the very
least a close friend however at times
their connection doesn't seem all that
different than that between a father and
a son Picard reveals part of his
fascination with and admiration for data
in the second season episode The Measure
of a Man data attempts to resign his
commission so that an insistent
Starfleet scientist can't run
experiments on him which will wipe out
his memory the scientist argues data as
a machine doesn't have the right to
resign his commission and Picard assumes
the difficult task of proving that data
is a sentient being with the right to
make his own choices and not be
subjected to anyone else's ownership
Picard famously tells the presiding
judge
Starfleet was founded to seek out new
life well there it sits data Is
tragically forced to sacrifice himself
at the end of the final Next Generation
film 2002's Star Trek nemesis when
Picard is appointed as Arbiter of
succession by the dying Klingon
Chancellor kempack he helps alter the
course of the Klingon Empire as Arbiter
Picard's job is to weigh the worth of
the two Challengers galron and duras by
the end of season 4's reunion kempek is
dead and no new chancellor has been
officially announced things get even
more complicated when Wharf claiming
Vengeance for the death of his mate
kalar at duras's hands transports over
to do Ross's ship and kills him Picard
finally announces gauron as the rightful
Chancellor but two Klingon sisters from
the house of duras appear with a boy
named Toro who they claim is the son of
duras and should therefore be considered
a Challenger in the right the card later
confirms Toro is the son of duras but
that he is too young and inexperienced
to be considered Chancellor the decision
pushes the Klingon Empire into open
Civil War eventually the house of
duras's conspiracy with the romulans is
exposed and galaron presides over a
reunited Empire as an added benefit
Wharf and his house are redeemed in the
eyes of his people
in spite of their respective series
being separated by two decades Jean-Luc
Picard proves to be an important figure
in the life of Spock the first time
Picard significantly touches Spock's
life is in the third season's saric
Spock himself doesn't appear but his
father sarek boards the Enterprise to
negotiate a trade deal with the
ligarians unfortunately it soon becomes
clear that sarek suffers from a rare
degenerative disorder that causes his
emotions to run wild the card agrees to
a mind meld so that sarik can maintain
enough control to continue with the
negotiations
I mind
to your mind
in the two-part unification Picard comes
face to face with Spock himself he's
sent to Romulus to find Spock because
Starfleet fears the Vulcan may have
defected to their Rivals instead Picard
learns Spock is involved in secret
negotiations with the hopes of bringing
the Vulcan and Romulan People Back
Together by the end of the two-parter
sarik finally succumbs to his illness
and unification ends with a
compassionate and tender gesture on
Picard's part he allows Spock to mind
meld with him so that Spock May connect
with the parts of his father that Picard
had experienced of all the Star Trek
series of the past six decades none can
boast as inventive or satisfying a
finale as all good things the final
episode of The Next Generation Q causes
Picard to jump both backwards and
forwards in time so that the story takes
place in the present past and decades in
the future where Picard is an older man
suffering from a degenerative mental
disease Picard's trips to the Future are
particularly difficult with future
versions of Beverly Crusher data and
Jordy laforge all aware of his condition
it makes it that much more challenging
to convince anyone in that time that he
actually is experiencing what he says
he's experiencing I know what you're
thinking it's the iramotic syndrome
he's beginning to lose his mind the old
man well it's not that and I'm not
daydreaming either none of the TNG
movies hinted towards the illness
beginning to emerge and the future of
the episode was only one possible
timeline when the next Generation crew
gets on the big screen for the first
time in 1994's Star Trek generations it
sadly comes with the death of William
Shatner's Captain Kirk and unfortunately
Jean-Luc Picard suffers some much more
personal losses both in the beginning
and at the end of the game-changing film
early in Generations the Enterprise's
empathic counselor Deanna Troy senses
something is terribly wrong and when she
finds Captain Picard flipping through a
photo album Jean-Luc reveals he's just
received news that his brother Robert
and his son have been killed in a fire
the usually stoic Picard laments the
loss of his beloved nephew and reflects
that without a wife or children of his
own he'll be the last one in his family
line I've come to feel that Renee was as
close as I would get down in China
by the end of the movie Picard loses the
Enterprise itself the ship barely
survives a battle with a Klingon bird of
prey run by the villainous sisters lursa
and batur the crew evacuates to the
ship's saucer section which crashes on
the surface of Viridian 3. thankfully as
Picard predicts the Enterprise D won't
be the last ship to carry the name
Enterprise the final big screen
appearance of Jean-Luc Picard comes with
2002's Star Trek Nemesis the Enterprise
is sent to Romulus to meet the Romulan
Empire's new leader who we soon learn
has an unexpected connection to Picard
as it turns out Prater shinzon is a
clone of Jean-Luc the romulans cloned
the captain in hopes of one day
replacing him with their own identical
agent but when one of the Empire's many
power shifts took place the Clone was
sent to a labor Colony with the enslaved
people of Remus shinzon lures Picard to
Romulus because the cloning process that
created him is now killing him and his
only potential cure is a complete blood
transfusion with Picard ultimately
shenzhan's plan plans to kill Picard and
destroy the Federation are foiled and
the Clone villain dies fighting his
older counterpart on top of all that
Nemesis includes huge shifts in Picard's
life including the loss of Riker as his
number one we learn early in the film
that Riker is finally taking the
captain's chair on the USS Titan and his
new wife Deanna Troy is coming with him
Picard means for data to replace Riker
as his first officer but the Android
sacrifices himself to save his friends
in the final battle in anticipation of
Star Trek Picard IDW released the
prequel mini-series Star Trek Picard
Countdown the story takes place six
years after the events of Nemesis and 14
years before Picard Picard is an admiral
commanding the USS Verity Romulus star
is close to going Supernova and the
Romulan Empire abandons some of its
usual paranoia and secrecy for
starfleet's help unfortunately
complications arise when Picard travels
to the Romulan colony of yuyat beta the
romulans there have Enslaved the native
population and neglected to Telstar wait
because in the words of one of the
colonies Romulan leaders evacuating them
would be as ridiculous as evacuating the
rocks and trees when Picard refuses to
relocate the romulans without the
natives the colony's leaders take him
and his first officer prisoner countdown
gives us a chance to see Rafi musakir
the irreverent first officer who insists
on referring to Picard as JL in action
as Picard's second in command during the
Romulan evacuation we also meet the
romulans zabon and Laris while they're
still tall shiar agents and it's
revealed exactly how they eventually
come to work for and live with Picard
after the events of countdown are
resolved Picard and Rafi prepare to
scramble a massive Fleet to relocate the
population of the twin Romulan
homeworlds the fleet is assembled at the
Utopia planisha shipyards with a
Workforce of mostly Android synths in a
shocking turn of events however a plot
masterminded by a Romulan Splinter Group
orchestrates a synth Uprising in a
historical attack on Mars the assaulted
destroys the entire Romulan rescue
Armada the card does manage to get some
Romulan refugees moved to the planet
vashti however the destruction of the
fleet leaves his relocation plan in
tatters and results in a ban on
synthetic life forms desperate to
fulfill his promise to rescue the
Romulan people Picard makes a plea to
Starfleet he wants to assemble a fleet
of formerly mothballed ships and
threatens to resign if they refuse but
in a shocking twist Starfleet command
accepts his resignation haunted by his
failures and unable to muster the same
kind of respect he had in his prime
Picard leaves Starfleet behind and goes
into seclusion at his Vineyard he
relocates a number of Romulan refugees
to his home including his Romulan
friends Laris and zabon
trekkies were surprised when they tuned
in to Picard for the first time instead
of the Bold commanding Captain they
recalled from TNG they saw a dreary
tired old man following his failure to
save Romulus Picard spends more than a
decade living a solitary life he has
only infrequent visits with old friends
from his days on the Enterprise and the
Stargazer but his quiet life in France
is upended by the arrival of a young
woman named Dodge this visitor appears
to be The Offspring of his old friend
data and she's being hunted by
mysterious unknown forces he has
everything inside of me says that I'm
safe with you as it turns out Dodge is
actually a synthetic life form and she
may be the key to stopping an emerging
Galactic threat without the clout he had
in his Heyday Picard is forced to
recruit a new crew this includes Dr
Agnes girati Rogue pilot Cristobal Rios
a young Romulan monk named Eleanor and
his old friend Rafi they take on a
mission to unravel a conspiracy and stop
a cosmic cataclysm after several deep
tours he finally finds the destination
of Dodge's twin sister she's working at
the Borg Reclamation project there
Picard is reunited with the former Borg
drone named Hugh who's taken it upon
himself to assist other Borg to regain
their former lives more than just
another chance to play Hero Picard's
Mission also allows him to finally come
to terms with the death of commander
data while the story in season one of
Star Trek Picard is kicked off by the
discovery of data's daughter the action
is propelled by a mystery involving the
synths and a threat that could wipe out
all life in the galaxy from his Romulan
housekeepers Picard learns that the
threat may involve the jot vosh to get
to the bottom of the conspiracy Picard
and the crew of Captain rios's La Serena
must track down the scientist Bruce
Maddox the mission is completely
unsanctioned and it makes Picard a rogue
agent in an unlikely role reversal
during the mission Picard meets doja's
twin sister soji and is reunited with
old friends Will Riker and Deanna Troy
for the first time in many years they
help get him information regarding a
planet called capelius it's there that a
new race of synthetic life forms is
being created which the zotvash believe
poses an existential threat to the
Galaxy as the planet comes under attack
from a Romulan Fleet the current gets
assistance from Riker who commands a
federation Fleet to stop them in the
aftermath Picard successfully convinces
star Fleet to lift the ban on synthetic
life allowing soji and others like them
to live in peace the end of the first
season of Picard includes a
life-altering change in the story of the
former captain of the Enterprise in the
aftermath of the Romulan Federation
clash in the skies above capellius
Picard finally succumbs to the apparent
iromotic syndrome that has long plagued
him and he dies surrounded by his new
crew but on capelius Picard gets a
second chance at life also on capelius
is data's human brother Elton soon who
has created a bio-organic Golem body
with the help of gerardi suing is able
to transfer Picard's Consciousness into
this new Golem which is given the form
of Picard's old body before the transfer
completes though Picard's mind is
transferred into a simulation module
where the consciousness of data also
resides as Picard and data speak
Picard's old friend makes one final
request when you leave
I would be profoundly grateful if you
terminated my Consciousness resurrected
in his new body Picard enters the
simulation again and says a tearful
goodbye as he shuts down data's program
one final time in his new body Jean-Luc
Picard still has the form of an elderly
man but is free of his aromatic syndrome
healthy enough to live decades more he
sets out with a renewed spirit and
returns to active Starfleet Duty he's
accepted back into the service and
appointed to the role of Chancellor of
Starfleet Academy as season 2 of Picard
begins jean-luc's life has begun to
settle down again but an old rival shows
up to make trouble it turns out to be
the not so Immortal cue in season 2 of
Star Trek Picard much like he has in the
past Q arrives to teach Picard a
valuable life lesson and he does it by
throwing Picard and his new crew into an
alternate timeline where Starfleet is a
fascist dictatorship and Picard is their
iron-fisted Tyrant ruler through a
mirror Darkly
hear the man who holds the glass is
darker still in this Twisted reality the
Federation is known as the Confederation
and Picard has defeated all of its
greatest enemies this includes
luminaries from Star Trek including
Klingon General Martock cardassian gold
ducat even beheading sarik director of
the Vulcan Science Academy Picard has to
travel back in time to save the future
to solve the mystery of altered
existence Picard needs the help of the
Borg Queen he also has to come face to
face with his own history when he meets
Renee Picard she's an ancestor of
jean-lukes who also plays a key role in
the history of space exploration in the
21st century her mission to Europa is
critical to ensuring the federation's
future
season three of Star Trek Picard was
heavily promoted as the reunion of the
crew of the Enterprise D and it's
because of an emerging threat from one
of the federation's most deadly foes
after using the USS Titan to come to the
rescue of his dear friend and on-again
off-again lover Beverly Crusher the card
uncovers a conspiracy to infiltrate the
Federation the threats begin to unravel
as they encounter a mercenary pirate
named vodick she is one of the leaders
of the conspiracy and the first foe
Picard and his allies have to defeat in
order to bring an end to the emerging
threat vodic is a rogue changeling who
spent much of her life as a prisoner and
was tortured by section 31 following the
end of the Dominion War she's bent on
Revenge and needs Picard's son to
achieve it with the help of the Titan's
jaded Captain Liam Shaw and his first
officer seven of nine they helped keep
his son safe but the reasons for the
pursuit remain unclear
season 3 of Star Trek Picard introduces
Jack Crusher the son of Jean-Luc Picard
and Beverly Crusher whose Discovery
forever Alters Jean-Luc Picard's life he
is the product of a whirlwind romance
following the events of Star Trek
Nemesis Dr Crusher hid him from Picard
because she feared he might become the
target of his father's worst enemies to
keep him a secret Dr Crusher cut off all
contact with Jean-Luc and the rest of
her old Enterprise Shipmates alongside
his mother Jack grew up on the edges of
the Federation Frontier helping to
provide Aid and supplies to those in
need but they came under attack from
what would later be revealed to be enemy
changeling agents and they were forced
to go to Jean-Luc for help Picard is
heartbroken that he had been denied the
opportunity to be a father for more than
20 years and you never thought
if you had told me
it all might have been different despite
the years of secrecy Picard helps keep
Dr Crusher and Jack safe from their
pursuers with the aid of Riker Picard
hijacks the USS Titan to do it and
exposes the changeling plot ultimately
it's revealed that Jack inherited a part
of jean-luc's Borg assimilated biology
the changeling vodick was working with
the Borg Queen to use Jack as part of a
plan to assimilate and destroy the
Federation as Vox jack controls the
newly created Borg drones and almost
destroys Earth but after Picard makes a
heartfelt plea to his son within the
Borg Collective unconscious Jack rejects
the queen and the pair thwart her
diabolical plans
foreign